this used to be one of the main
hospitals in kiev dealing with covid19
infections
it's now been repurposed to treat war
casualties this ukrainian volunteer was
shot in erpine north of kiev while
defending the capital from intense
russian attacks
despite being shot three times he wants
to go back to the front lines
of course i want to fight again i will
join the territorial defense here in
kiev as soon as i can
i want to join my friends in the fight
when they brought me to the hospital
they told me i had some shrapnel in my
lung but it turned out to be a bullet
there's a defiant spirit amongst doctors
nurses and administration staff who say
they're already working around the clock
will definitely sustain all medical
services on top of that the ukrainian
army and the territorial defense are
keeping the enemy from entering the city
we are ready to give emergency medical
and rehabilitation services to all and
any that are suffering from this
horrible war
despite the defiance hospitals
nationwide are facing a crisis 43 have
been attacked since the war began
in the besieged city of mariopol staff
and patients were taken hostage as
russian soldiers use the hospital to
fire on ukrainian forces
similar scenes across the country have
provoked condemnation from the world
health organization
to attack the most vulnerable babies
children pregnant women and those
already suffering from illness and
disease and health workers
risking their own lives to save lives is
an act of unconscionable cruelty that's
an incredibly strong statement from the
who
but with the war intensifying around the
capital many are wondering whether
hospitals like this and the ones that
are left will become overwhelmed imran
khan al jazeera kev
to moscow now where russia's president
vladimir putin has again been talking
about the impact severe sanctions are
having he was referring to crimea which
russia annexed from ukraine back in
2014.
yes of course without a doubt the
peninsula's economic development has
been affected by the western sanctions
imposed among others on banking good
supplies etc but after the military
operation in ukraine started a new set
of sanctions were imposed yesterday at
the meeting on social economic measures
to support russian regions i said that
the restrictions against russia have
created a lot of issues but not only
issues they are also creating new
opportunities for us
and the latest briefing from russia's
foreign ministry showed no shift in
moscow's demands for establishing a
ceasefire
our purpose is quite clear kiev will
have to realize they have to agree to
carry out demilitarization and
denationalization the sooner the key
regime realizes this the sooner the war
will end we call on president zielenski
to think about the life of the country
and its citizens and make the necessary
decisions
turkey has renewed its push to bring the
leaders of ukraine and russia to the
negotiating table bennett smith has more
on that from moscow
regime type erdogan has continued
talking with vladimir putin and he has
said that it's time for vladimir
zelensky and vladimir putin to meet
face-to-face there are certain issues
that they need to talk about
face-to-face it's the second time he's
offered to host talks in turkey between
the two leaders
but it seems the prospect of that could
be a very long way away we're also
having
western uh sources quoted by reuters
earlier today saying that while the
talks are continuing on both sides are
serious in their talks very
large gaps remain
between the two sides
and you've just heard the foreign
ministry spokeswoman saying
uh that the the long-standing demands of
russia
what they call d
get rid of nationalist groups in ukraine
this is what russia has long been using
as his excuse for its uh what it calls a
special operation in ukraine it says
ukraine must get rid of these groups d
nazi fire has been another word russia
uh has used in terms of describing the
government of vladimir zelensky so that
sort of talk is an indication of while
the two sides are talking there's a huge
gap between what both sides want
particularly as we know that russia
wants crimea and donette's going to lose
gans recognized uh crimea recognized as
part of russia and unexcused recognized
as independent states
ukraine's president vladimir zelinski
meanwhile has been given a standing
ovation from germany's parliament he
urged chancellor olof schultz to do more
to bring an end to russia's invasion and
he's warned that european countries care
more about their economies than the
lives of regular ukrainians his address
to the bundestag came a day after a
speech to the us congress
we are fighting for our lives and for
our freedom it is not the berlin wall it
is the wall between having freedom and
not having freedom in europe with every
bomb and every decision not made that
could have helped us this wall is
getting bigger
we asked about what ukraine can do to
join nato and getting security
guarantees and the answer we received is
that it isn't on the table
now you question whether ukraine should
join the eu yes for some this is
politics but for us it is souls for the
new wall
but nato secretary general jens
stoltenberg visiting berlin again warned
against a fully-fledged war between the
alliance and russia
nato has a responsibility to prevent
this conflict from escalating further
that would be even more dangerous and
would cause more suffering death and
destruction
this is president putin's war
he must stop the war
withdraw his forces and engage in the in
diplomacy in good faith